will ich das video hier gerade aufnehmen
no money no fun i ich verkaufe meinen
bruder erstes hilf mir was will man
erwarten dass sportlich
wie sie sich jetzt ausziehen und zudem
hinlaufen jetzt zugriff rein und spiele
einfach mit denen mit
über folgen doch das ist meine chance
zugelassen die chance gewartet
ja das ist die beste
sie ergeben kann der grad
basketballtraining und du stets mit im
holzfällerhemd und einer jeans
[Musik]
was eigentlich
du spielst basketball in so einer halle
und auf einmal kommt im rennteam girl
reingelaufen wird zum holzfäller hemd
und jeans aber das holz thailand so hoch
geknotet und nimmt den ball weg wie soll
das weitergehen
[Musik]
ich hab gesagt christus mit der held
dennis erzielen müssen trainieren und
richtig
aber die wiederum mit spielen mensch
[Musik]
erkennen
willst du doch und zählt das war sagen
dass er seinen namen kennt das eine
gleiche schule das logisch dass jeder
den namen vom anhang
was
auch zur schule die zähne aus mitte 30
[Musik]
die folge ist nicht mal zwei minuten alt
und mir steht das wasser schon wieder
passiert wahrscheinlich eher hässlich
mehr das ganze der bilder wie aus dem
drehbuch das ist ja unfassbar wie so
wird das nicht unbedingt neue
unterwäsche kaufen weil welches zusammen
kommen eigentlich nicht so gut
ausschauen und er was mache ich mein
taschengeld 30 euro/monat er kommt ja ja
die titel steht ja schon verkauft als
sein bruder herrschen geld tabelle des
jugendamtes bietet eltern eine gute
richtschnur für die bemessung der höhe
des richtschnur
das wort existiert mich bruder ist lisa
von christen
der jetzt will sie wahrscheinlich mit
dieser elisa also der schwester von
christ ins gespräch kommen um über die
an christ ranzukommen wie sieht jetzt
auch den basketball oder was macht
seitdem mit band im jahr heute zum
ersten mal und hamburg auf
[Musik]
hey was soll mit beim training
aha ist also dein erstes mal hats
nachher work auf eis aber und ich mache
das immer noch ein training darum aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
da kann man nicht nein sagen
benny denise wir runde heise austria so
sei unfassbar
komm schon bitter bitter nach ok nach
reis essen
[Musik]
da kannst du für mich von der brücke
springen wir gehen auch nachher eisessen
fall schön dass du gekommen bist ja
ich bin doch nachher schönes essen
dieses all dies für 30 cent hat ob
ausmachen der ist total cool dass ich
gut auch schon das weiß ich bereits
[Musik]
[Applaus]
folge dass sie vielleicht wieder drauf
danke dass ich top aus jetzt weiß ich
bereit du willst ja fast als würde ich
mich nicht ganz zuschlagen und zu texten
dennoch diese spielklasse ist die erste
was mein bruder will
ich glaube dass diese elisa sich ein
bisschen verarscht vorkommen dass jeder
nur mit ihr befreundet sein will weil
sie an ihrem bruder reinkommen wollte
inhaltlich kann süß ganzes unterschied
ist ja vollkommen von kleinen den ja
okay ich bin halt von paulsons vor allem
sein lachen
ich finde den ganz ganz süß vorne
übertrieben
ja ich finde schon voll süß ja ich frage
mich ich frage mich gibt tipps wie du
mein bruder reinkommst und bekomme ich
geld habe ich wenig eis oder so einen
kram sehen will bar gesehen
[Musik]
ich
der blick von ihr sagt glaube ich alles
sie weiß ganz genau wann er sich wo
aufhält und worauf er steht ja kommen
wir machen das was cool
cool
im gegenzug bekommt die schwester von
christian monatliche flatrate ich glaube
sie denn es gefällt christian mit
sicherheit als würde darum geben wenn
der tier wäre ja hexen kann ich mich
aber ich kann den vorschlag machen
für nochmal 40 euro könnte ich dich mit
schulungs nehmen und
was will die denn kein geld alter ja
schon so aufgeregt nervt mich nicht wenn
man nicht nervt doch gar nicht ich
wollte doch nur packen und chris kommt
jetzt gib mir mal die kohle rüber chris
wird schon gleich kommen die e dieser
art richtig bock die ist richtig mit
wird voller begeisterung bei ihrem neuen
beruf der ihn gar nicht wahrgenommen
ich wollte ist eigentlich eine ganz
nette kannst sagen komm jetzt eine
freundin
oh mein gott oh mein gott ich dachte
halt irgendwie noch so auf der einen
seite dass diese schwester von ihm als
sie diese elisa die halt der denise die
ganzheit die tipps gibt dass sie
zumindest denkt dass der christ
vielleicht auch sie stehen könnte aber
die seine total ausgefuchste die weiß
dass ihr bruder der freundin hat und
will einfach nur ein bisschen geld
mitnehmen menschen sind sämtlich
abstoßen schacht und glücklich bist seit
zwei jahren obwohl sie in anderen stadt
wohnen schild für dich übrigens morgen
bei dabei auch noch gut zu kommen serena
hat mir gesagt ich soll die fragen ich
will nix mehr
die sind seit zwei jahren zusammen
was du wirklich dringend los aber erst
gefragt gefragt was wir genau machst und
optional klamotten hast
was ist das für eine waffe
alt hat es ja unfassbar was hier abzieht
sag mal weißwasser vielleicht morgen tja
ich schon aber was er in sich nun gegen
bares
diese idee war ein geschäftsmann
ich habe gehört dass chrismon in der
pipe ist mit freunden weiß so gutes
[Musik]
ich dachte der titel bezieht sich auf
die denise die geld braucht für weitere
tipps und dafür verkauft sie ihren
bruder aber es geht um elisa die ihren
bruder verkauft weil sie geld dem
philips die libeskind oh mein gott wenn
ich dann aber gut schauen wir mal was an
dieser halfpipe da passiert ist
das ist seine freundin
ok jetzt wird spannend ach du stehst
also auf zu viel
hä
das würde komische queens situation
gerade die bestimmt noch aus zeiten von
deiner oma das kleid oder hey das ist ja
das ist ja die sehr komplett frisch
also irgendwie diese schwester vom von
chris ist er und seine freundin ist ja
auch die übelste auf der ganzen welt
es ist ja unfassbar mit welchen leuten
hängen der ab
warum beendet ihr da die folge könnt ihr
nicht mal die komplette folge hochladen
hilft mir aber gut männer lieben freude
an der stelle würde ich meine reaktion
hierauf hilf mir mal wieder jetzt auch
beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
ihr da schreibt hintergrund in die
kommentare auf welches wichtig als
dieses reagieren soll und jetzt kommt
das auto
[Musik]